[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN CHAI: Location
data brings some
of the most useful and rich
and amazing experiences
to users on mobile devices.
Things like, turn
by turn directions.
When was the last
time you pulled out
a paper map to figure out how
to get from point A to point B?
And if a road was
closed, rerouting
was pulling over to
reconsult your paper map.
Or worse yet, having to
actually talk to somebody
to ask for directions.
Next, recording the distance
of a hike or a run or a bicycle
ride.
It's never been easier
to map your route,
or monitor your progress
whether you're just
a casual runner, or training
for something specific.
And of course, discovering
new restaurants and places
of interest.
It's become so easy to
find the best places
to eat, to drink, to
sightsee, and of course--
most importantly-- the best
places to take selfies.
Now you can get reviews
and recommendations
from thousands of
other users, instead
of just consulting the
people that you know,
or buying a guide which
gets obsolete over time.
However, location data
is also some of our most
personal information.
As you heard in our
keynote yesterday,
privacy and security have been
an important part of Android
since the beginning.
And it is a core part of
Android Q. In Android Q,
we extend transparency
and control to users
for their location data.
Next, Praveen and Wei are
going to dive into the details.
But let me start
with two driving
principles that grounded how
we thought about these changes.
As a user, you want to be
in control of your data.
And you only want
to share location
with apps when it makes sense.
We want to provide simple,
discoverable, and easy
to understand controls
to users so they
know what apps have
access to their location,
and whether it's on or off.
We'll talk in this
session about how
we're bringing more
control to users about when
apps can access their location.
Second, we want users
to have transparency
over what apps have
access to their location,
especially when it
might be unexpected.
We'll also talk about how we're
providing helpful reminders
to users about when apps
are accessing their location
when in the background, so
they can determine whether they
want to continue that or not.
Next, I'll hand it to
Praveen to get us started.
PRAVEEN CHANDRAN: Thanks.
Hey, everyone.
Very good morning to
all of you, and thanks
for joining us today.
I'm Praveen Chandran.
I'm a product manager in the
Android Location Services team.
As Jen said, we would like to
provide simple, discoverable,
easy to understand
controls for users
to be able to control
access to location data.
Users only want to
share sensitive data--
like location-- with
apps when it makes sense.
So in Android Q, we have
added the ability for users
to control which apps can access
their device location when
they're not using the app.
Now, before Android
Q, location permission
was really a binary choice
in that a user could either
allow or deny access to
their device location.
If a user provided location
permission to an app,
the app could get access to
the user's device location
when the user was using the app,
but also when the user was not
using the app.
In Android Q, we have introduced
a new location permission--
allow only while using the app.
If a user chooses
this option, the app
would be able to get access
to the user's device location
only when the user
is using the app.
For this new
permission, how do we
define when the app is in use?
Well, there are two scenarios.
For this permission,
an app is considered
to be in use when
the user is looking
at the app on their
device screen,
which is commonly known
as a foreground activity,
or when the app is running
a foreground service.
What's a good example
of a foreground service?
Let us say, you're
using a navigation app
and you have requested turn by
turn directions from the app.
While the app is providing
turn by turn directions,
if you hit on the home button
to get to the home screen,
or you turn on the
device screen altogether,
you would notice that the
navigation app would continue
to provide directions even when
you are on the home screen.
Now, that's a good example of an
app using a foreground service.
For the rest of
this presentation,
whenever we refer to
an app being in use
or when we say an app
is in the foreground,
we are referring to foreground
activity or foreground service.
And every other type of
activity is considered
to be background activity.
In a few minutes, I'll
talk about some changes
in Q related to
getting location when
running a foreground service.
But before I talk about that,
let me delve a little bit more
into the details of
this new permission.
To get location
permission, you need
to declare ACCESS_FINE_LOCATION
or ACCESS_COARSE_LOCATION
in the manifest.
Typically, coarse location
is at the city level,
while fine location is
as best as we can do.
Before Android Q, if you had
specified ACCESS_FINE_LOCATION,
or ACCESS_COARSE_LOCATION
in the manifest,
your app could get
location in the foreground,
and in the background.
In Android Q, if your
app is targeting QSDK,
you should add a declaration
for ACCESS_BACKGROUND_LOCATION
in the manifest,
if your app needs
to access the user's device
location in the background
because your current declaration
of ACCESS_FINE_LOCATION,
or ACCESS_COARSE_LOCATION
will only
let your app access the
device location when
the app is in the foreground.
However, if your app
is targeting pre-QSDK,
your existing declaration
of ACCESS_FINE_LOCATION
or ACCESS_COARSE_LOCATION
would automatically
be mapped to
ACCESS_BACKGROUND_LOCATION.
And there really is no
way for apps to opt out
of this automatic mapping.
Now, one of the key
benefits of targeting QSDK
is that if your app needs
location permission only
when the app is
in the foreground,
you can choose to request
only this location
permission from the
user, and get location
when the app is in use.
In other words,
you can choose not
to request location permission
when the app is not in use,
or rather, if the app
is in the background.
As a best practice, we
highly recommend developers
to utilize this
capability and always
ask only for the permission
needed for the app.
Another key benefit
of targeting QSDK
is that your app can now make
incremental location permission
requests.
And incremental
permission requests
are incredibly helpful in
presenting the location
permission dialog whenever
the user accesses the feature.
Again, as a best
practice, we recommend
developers show the permission
dialog when the user accesses
the relevant feature, so
that the user can understand
why an app is asking for
a certain permission,
or even for a certain
level of permission.
Let us say your app
needs to access location
in the foreground and/or
in the background.
Users are much more likely
to grant the level of access
needed for your app when users
are requested to evaluate
these permissions
requests separately,
and at the time that they are
accessing the relevant feature.
Let's take this example
of My Train Commute
app, which helps users
manage their train commute.
This app would provide the
train schedule of a nearby train
station based on the
user's location, when
the user is looking at the app.
And this app would send
train commute notifications
when the user is not
actively looking at the app,
based on the user's
background location.
Now for this app,
when the user opens
the app for the first
time and the user wants
to access train
schedules, at that time,
the app can show the dialog
that you see on the screen,
requesting only
while-in-use permission.
And the user is
likely to understand
why the app is asking
for this permission,
saying, yeah, I get it.
In order to get the train
schedule of a nearby station,
this app needs to
know my location now.
And the user would be much
more likely to provide
this permission.
Let us say the user has
provided this permission.
Then, the user looks
around the app,
reaches the train commute
notifications feature,
wants to opt in to train
commute notifications.
At that point in
time, the app can
show the permission
dialog that you see here,
requesting the user to provide
the higher level of access,
which is the ability to
access the device location all
the time.
If the dialog is
presented at that time,
the user would think, in
order to send a notification,
this app needs to access my
location in the background.
I get it.
So I'll provide this
level of access.
As you can see from the dialog,
in the incremental permission
request the user would
have two options.
Either to allow the app to
access the device location all
the time, or to say, keep
the current level of access.
I don't want to provide
the higher level of access.
Now, to force request permission
to access device location only
in the foreground, you can
specify, ACCESS_COARSE_LOCATION
or ACCESS_FINE_LOCATION in the
request permissions method.
And if the user
allows, your app would
be able to access device
location in the foreground.
How do you request users for
a higher level of access,
or rather the ability to
access device location
in the background?
As a best practice, we recommend
developers to first check
if your app has access to device
location in the foreground.
If it does, then you can specify
ACCESS_BACKGROUND_LOCATION
in the Request
Permissions method
to request a user for this
higher level of access.
On that note, how do you
know if your app has access
to your device location
in the foreground,
and/or in the background?
You can use the
checkSelfPermission method
to see if your app has been
granted ACCESS_FINE_LOCATION
or ACCESS_COARSE_LOCATION
permission.
And if it has been
granted, your app
can access the user's device
location in the foreground.
You can use the
same method to check
if the app has
ACCESS_BACKGROUND_LOCATION
permission granted.
And if it has been
granted, your app
can now access the user's device
location in the background.
A key aspect to think about
with this new permission
is what is the impact of
this new location permission
based on the SDK version
targeted by your app?
Users will be able to set
while-in-use permission
for apps requesting location
permission in Android Q.
Users could go to
Settings and change
the permission of your app from
all the time, to while-in-use.
What does that
mean for your app?
If your app is
targeting PSDK or lower,
your app could get
into a situation
where your app is
expecting location updates
in the background,
but the user would
have changed the
location permission
for your app to while-in-use.
At that point in time, your
app cannot get location updates
in the background, due to
which some features that are
dependent on background location
may not work as intended.
We highly suggest developers
to handle the situation
graciously, and make
sure the features that
are dependent on
background location
would provide the right
messaging to the user,
letting them know that
the app doesn't have
this level of access, or make
sure the features continue
to work as intended, even
without background location.
We also highly recommend
developers to test and upgrade
to QSDK as early as possible.
Now for this new permission,
another key aspect
to think about is what
would happen to the location
permission of apps when a
user upgrades their device
from Android Pie to Android Q?
Well, the apps which had
location permission in Android
Pie would continue to
retain the permissions even
after the device upgrade.
In other words, if an app had
location permission in Android
Pie, the app would be able
to access the user's device
location in the foreground,
and in the background--
even after the device upgrade.
We chose to retain location
permissions for apps on OS
upgrade, so that the user
experiences do not break
and the apps-- or the
features of the apps--
continue to work as intended.
A few slides back, we
talked about when an app
was considered to be in use.
And at that point, I'd said
we'll talk a little bit more
about foreground services.
In Q, we are
introducing some changes
to how apps can get device
location when they are
running a foreground service.
But before we talk
about the change, let's
for a moment understand the
need for accessing location when
running a foreground service.
When using an app, the
user might use a feature
that requires the app to
access their device location,
even after the user
gets to the home screen
by hitting the Home button,
or if the user turns off
their device screen.
A good example, again,
would be the navigation app
that we spoke about
a few minutes ago.
Now, in the navigation
app, if you remember,
the user initiated an action
in the app requesting the app
to provide turn by
turn directions.
And while the app was providing
the turn by turn directions,
the user hit the Home button
to get to the home screen.
In such cases, the app should
continue the action initiated
by the user, and continue to
get location to provide turn
by turn directions.
In this example, the app would
use a foreground service,
and needs to access
location when
running a foreground service.
Typically, whenever an app needs
to continue an action initiated
by the user in the
app, the app would need
to use a foreground service.
Now, users expect this
type of navigation to work,
even if the app only
has while-in-use access.
To be in line with the
user's expectations,
the apps need to use
foreground service,
and need to continue
to get location when
running a foreground service.
What's new in Q
is that apps which
need to get location when
running a foreground service
need to declare foreground
service of type location
in the manifest.
We will be limiting
permission usage based
on this type of declaration.
You can declare foreground
service of type location
using the foreground service
type attribute in the service
element of the manifest file.
If you do not declare foreground
service of type location,
and if the user has provided
only while-in-use permission
to your app, your app cannot
get location when running
a foreground service.
If an app has
all-the-time access,
though, it can get location when
running a foreground service,
even without this
declaration in the manifest.
If an app specifies
foreground service
of type location
in the manifest,
the app has to compile
against the QSDK version.
Now, this changes for all apps,
irrespective of the target SDK
version.
In other words, apps need to
declare foreground service
of type location in the
manifest if the app wants
to access location when
running a foreground service,
and the app has
either only requested
while-in-use
permission, or the user
has only provided while-in-use
permission to the app.
On that note, there was a
talk on adapting your apps
for Android Q
privacy requirements.
I think it was at
8:30, today, morning.
The talk was given by
Charmaine and Svet.
One of the aspects that was
discussed in that presentation
was the different types
of foreground service.
In this talk, I covered
foreground service
of type location.
If you would like to know about
the other types of foreground
service, I highly recommend
you should check out
that talk on YouTube later.
Now, at the beginning
of the session,
Jen talked about
providing more visibility
to the user on apps accessing
the user's device location.
As a way to bring more
transparency and visibility
to users in Android Q, we are
introducing location reminder
notifications.
Location information
is sensitive,
and users share sensitive
data-- like location--
when it makes sense.
But occasionally, users
could forget the level
of location permission
given to apps, especially
the less frequently used apps.
So we are going to gently nudge
the user with a notification
if the app accesses their device
location when the user is not
actively using the app.
Here is an example of what
that notification would
look like in Android
Q. In this case,
the My Train Commute app has
access to the user's location
when the app was not being used.
So the user gets
this notification,
and the notification
lets the user
know that this app can access
their device location all
the time.
At that point, when the user
taps on their notification,
the user will be directed
to the Location Permission
page of the app
where the user could
make a decision on the right
level of access for the app,
and can even choose to change
the permission to while-in-use,
or deny.
When does the user
get this notification?
The user will get a one-time
per app notification
when the user provides
all-the-time location
permission to an
app, and the app
receives fine location
update in the background.
To add a bit more
context, if the user
has provided
all-the-time access,
changes it to while-in-use,
or deny, and then eventually
in the future again reverts
it back to all-the-time,
the user might see the
notification again.
Till now, I have
covered the features
in Android Q intended to
provide more visibility
and control to users on
apps accessing their device
location.
I now request Wei
to come up on stage,
to talk about
location permission
considerations for Wi-Fi APIs.
[APPLAUSE]
WEI WANG: Thanks, Praveen.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Wei Wang.
I'm a software engineer for
the Android location team.
Praveen talked about more
control, and better visibility
of direct location access
through location service APIs
in Android Q.
However, on Android,
it's possible to get
indirect location
access from connectivity
APIs, especially Wi-Fi APIs.
As we all know,
Wi-Fi connectivity
is critical on mobile devices.
As Wi-Fi devices
become ubiquitous,
people connect to Wi-Fi
almost all the time.
They connect to Wi-Fi access
points to go to the internet,
and connect to local Wi-Fi
devices for peer-to-peer file
transfer, or
managing IoT devices.
Applications
sometimes want to have
users connect to Wi-Fi devices.
Before Q, Android provides
APIs for Wi-Fi connectivity.
Applications typically
do a Wi-Fi scan first,
to get a list of
nearby Wi-Fi networks,
and choose which Wi-Fi
device to connect to.
Knowing the nearby
Wi-Fi devices makes
it possible to derive
the device location.
So these APIs are protected
by location permission.
This causes a lot of
confusion to users,
as they just want to use the
app for Wi-Fi connectivity
and do not understand
why the app requested
location permission.
To solve this
problem on Android Q,
we're introducing two new Wi-Fi
APIs, Wi-Fi NetworkSuggestion,
and Wi-Fi NetworkSpecify.
Using theses APIs,
the application
can tell the Wi-Fi system
what Wi-Fi devices they want
to connect to, and the Wi-Fi
system will do the scan
and decide whether to
connect to those devices
when they are in range.
The key difference
from the pre-Q API
is, using the new
APIs, the application
will not get access to
the nearby Wi-Fi device
information.
So the application does not need
to request location permission.
Furthermore, to better
protect user privacy on Q,
all the Wi-Fi APIs that
have location information
will be protected by
FIND_LOCATION_PERMISSION.
We highly recommend
using the new APIs
for Wi-Fi connectivity, to avoid
requesting location permission
in your application.
Let's take a deeper
look at these APIs.
The first API I
want to talk about,
is Wi-Fi NetworkSuggestion.
One of the major case
for Wi-Fi connectivity
is to connect the mobile
device to the internet,
so users can browse the web,
or communicate with others.
Some applications may
know certain networks
that user can connect to when
they go to airports, libraries,
or coffee shops.
On Q, such apps can use
the Wi-Fi NetworkSuggestion
APIs to recommend those
networks to the Wi-Fi system.
Let's look at an example.
A local coffee shop wants
to provide Wi-Fi internet
to its customers when
they enter the store.
They want to recommend the
Wi-Fi network to the device
through the app called
My Coffee Shop so users
can connect automatically
when they enter the store.
Let's see how it works.
First, the app needs to
tell the Wi-Fi system what
network to connect to.
This is done by
setting either the SSID
or [INAUDIBLE] in a Wi-Fi
NetworkSuggestion object.
Also, the app needs to
tell the Wi-Fi system how
to connect to these networks.
So if any credentials are
needed for the Wi-Fi connection,
the app also needs to
provide that in the Wi-Fi
NetworkSuggestion object.
After that, it can simply
call addNetworkSuggestions
to add this suggestion
to Wi-Fi manager.
So we only use one
NetworkSuggestion as an example
here, but in practice,
the coffee shop
may own multiple,
different Wi-Fi networks,
and the app can add a
list of those suggestions.
After these suggestions
are successfully added,
Wi-Fi system will be able
to use these suggestions
for connection.
Once the Wi-Fi system
detects the network suggested
by the app is nearby,
and these apps are
based for Wi-Fi internet
connectivity at that moment,
it will show a notification
to let the users know
that a network suggested
by My Coffee Shop app
is available for connection,
and requests approval
from the user.
After a user approves the
suggestion, the next time,
the Wi-Fi system
will auto-connect
to the network suggested
by the same app,
if these networks are
the best for connectivity
at that moment.
So the My Coffee Shop app
only provides the suggestions.
It does not get access to
the nearby Wi-Fi device
information, and it does
not know that the suggestion
network has been connected.
So it has no location
access, and the app
does not need to request
location permission.
Occasionally, the
application may
want to know that the suggested
network has been connected.
For instance, the coffee
shop may require user login
before using their network.
And my coffee shop wants
log in users automatically
after the connection,
and that app
will be directing users
to a captive portal.
Wi-Fi NetworkSuggestion
provides the capability
for this purpose.
However, since the app knows the
location of the Wi-Fi network,
knowing the connection
has been established
makes it possible
for the application
to derive the device location.
So this app will now
request location permission.
Similar with the
previous example,
create a Wi-Fi
network suggestion
object with the SSID
and a credential
for the access point.
The key here is,
.setIsAppInteractionRequired
to indicate the application
wants to be notified when
the device has connected
to the suggested network.
Next, register a
broadcast receiver
to listen to WIFI NETWORK
SUGGESTION POST CONNECTION
broadcast.
This broadcast is sent
to the application
when the network suggested
by the app is connected.
And I've just said, knowing
the connection makes
it possible to derive
the device location,
so the broadcast is only
sent to applications
if it has been granted
always access fine location
permission.
So we recommend using
this capability only
when you have a very strong
user case of doing so.
So that's the network
suggestion API,
for suggesting access points
for internet connectivity.
Another [INAUDIBLE] case
for Wi-Fi connectivity
is connect to a
local Wi-Fi device
for peer-to-peer
Wi-Fi connectivity.
For instance, users may take
photos with action cameras
when they go skiing,
and would like
to transfer those photos to
the mobile phones later on.
How?
They may have a smart thermostat
that they want to set up
using the app on their phone.
For use cases like this,
we introduced a new Wi-Fi
NetworkSpecifier API
in Q. So here, we've
got an IoT device that
needs some initial setup.
It has no UI, so you
might need to plug this
into a computer for setup.
Or more easily, using the
Wi-Fi NetworkSpecifier API,
you can just power
up the device,
connect this to your
mobile phone through Wi-Fi,
and do a setup from application
running on the phone.
The app will need to specify
the SSID of the asset patterns
to match the IoT device.
The phone can do the scans
for the Wi-Fi devices,
making these patterns.
Once a matching Wi-Fi
device is found,
the system will pop up a
dialog requesting users
to connect and select
which device to connect to.
The system will
remember user choice,
and auto-connect to the same
device previously approved
by the user.
Similar with Wi-Fi
NetworkSuggestion API,
the application
doesn't have access
to the nearby Wi-Fi information,
so location permission
is not needed.
Now, let's take a look
at how to use this API.
First, you'll need to create
a Wi-Fi NetworkSpecifier,
and specify how you
find the peer devices.
You can either set the SSID
pattern, or BSSID pattern,
[INAUDIBLE] expression to
match the Wi-Fi devices you
want to find.
Next, create a network request
using the NetworkSpecifier.
So the purpose of
Wi-Fi NetworkSpecifier
is for peer to peer
Wi-Fi connection,
instead of internet
connectivity.
So it's required to remove
the internet connectivity
from the network request.
Once the network
request is created,
you can use the URL Connectivity
Manager APIs to request
connecting to the network.
As a recap, we just talked
about two new Wi-Fi APIs
for connectivity
without location access,
WifiNetworkSuggestions,
and WifiNetworkSpecifier.
These APIs provides the
capability for applications
to suggest access points or
connect local Wi-Fi devices.
Applications using these
APIs don't have access
to nearby Wi-Fi devices, so no
location permission is needed.
We recommend using these
APIs for Wi-Fi connectivity
purpose going forward,
especially applications
targeting QSDK wouldn't be able
to use the pre-Q APIs to auto
connect to a previously
configured access point
or config a new server network.
So these apps will need to
migrate to the new APIs.
And also, as I
previously mentioned,
all the Wi-Fi APIs that
have location information
will need access final location
permission on Q. With that,
Jen will come back to
talk about best practices
for [INAUDIBLE] location.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JEN CHAI: Thanks, Wei.
Now that we've taught you how
to update your apps for some
of the new changes
in Android Q, I'm
going to summarize by talking
through some of the best
practices.
First, don't use location
data if you don't need it.
As Wei just talked
about, any API
that provides
location-related information
will require the
location permission.
However, these new
Wi-Fi suggestion
and peer-to-peer APIs allow you
to implement connectivity use
cases, without using
location information.
And so if your app supports
these types of use cases,
we encourage you to migrate
to use these new APIs.
This will also make
the experience simpler
for your users.
Only ask for the
permission that you need.
One of the key benefits to
the while-in-use permission
is you can ask for that if
that's the only permission
that you need.
Don't ask for all-the-time
permission if all you need
is while-in-use.
This also makes the
decision simpler and more
straightforward for users.
Also, as we mentioned
in the manifest,
you can declare either Coarse
or Fine location permission.
As Praveen mentioned, Coarse
is approximately city level.
And there's some use cases--
such as weather-- that work
fine with just Coarse location.
So we encourage you to
evaluate all the features
within your app, and decide if
you really need Fine location.
Next, ask the user for
location permission in context.
We suggest surfacing the
location permission prompt
when the user interacts
with, or turns
on a specific feature in
your app that requires it.
This also helps
the user understand
why your application is asking.
We don't recommend surfacing
the permission prompt
on app startup,
unless it's absolutely
obvious to the user why.
Four-- consider an
incremental request.
As Praveen had
mentioned, you can
ask for a while-in-use
permission
first, when the user's
interacting with your app.
And then later, ask for
all-the-time permission
when the user is
specifically turning
on a feature that requires it.
And finally, gracefully
handle all levels
of location permission.
As always, users can change
the location permission
for any app at anytime.
We encourage you to
gracefully handle
when your app doesn't
have background
location, or any location.
We also recommend that
non-location features
within your app
continue to work,
even if you don't have
location permission.
Thank you for creating all
these amazing location based
experiences for our users.
We can do so much more today
than we ever thought possible.
And together, we can create
new, innovative experiences,
while keeping our users
and their data safe.
We hope the information that
we've provided to you today
is helpful in updating your apps
to Android Q. A quick reminder
that we have office hours
later today at 11:30,
and again tomorrow
morning, at 8:30 AM.
There's also a code lab on
location that you can try out.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]